I mean this when I say this that I
didn't truly start living until my
husband loved me wow and he was the
first person I ever dated I've dated
some wonderful men and some [__] mhm
but he was the first person who didn't
try to change anything about me and just
loved me wow and I there was such a
freedom and confidence that came out of
that um because he loved me and really
really really well and um allowed me to
just be myself and I finally for the
first time at 38 when I met him started
having fun again cuz I wasn't
embarrassed to be anything I was just
myself and started having fun and didn't
care what people thought of me because
this man loves me wow and it was really
beautiful and there was a lot of
strength in that that I got from him
just by loving me do you think you you
learned to love yourself when he started
loving you because you thought you were
yeah I did wow yeah because I my husband
is probably the best man I've ever met
my dad's phenomenal I'm not talking
about my family my husband is such a
good kind man and I recognized from the
moment I met him that he was going to
make some woman very happy one
day and so the moment that he chose
me I literally in my mind
went oh my God I must not be that bad
like I must actually be beauti person
that's beautiful and sad at the same
time yeah and yeah yeah you felt worthy
I did you made you feel like you it made
you feel not that worthy like it just
made you feel good enough
and for and stop just good enough good
enough good enough yeah good enough more
than I had never felt good enough and
because I'd never felt good enough for
other people I didn't feel good enough
for myself I felt my entire life like I
needed to be better I needed to be
somebody else I needed to be anything
but me because me wasn't enough and when
I found someone who I loved and who I
saw them as this amazing person and that
person loved me it immediately made me
realize I didn't have to be anything
other than myself and it was the most
freeing thing that's ever happened to me
and I truly started to like become
myself that is the key to meet
someone whose agenda is not to change
you yeah you know but it could be anyone
right it doesn't necessarily have to be
a romantic partner I think that that it
could be anyone that you encounter in
your life that you respect as a human
being if that person says you're enough
just believe them